so we got this video on how girls like
to hit on guys
and so I'm just gonna pop this is gonna
be a flop I know it give it a chance no
I don't get a chance lot of this music
sound like two robots was having orgasms
low any girl says hello like that I just
assume they work at Macy's or some get
the pump pump what pom-poms
you ain't got no titties hold up wait a
minute I'm not even saying that that's
the bad thing that you have new titties
don't advertise something you don't have
hey I noticed she wants to show her
pom-poms but she's not showing the guys
are pom pom like you make no sense
basically what you're doing is showing
your back to the dude oh yeah that's one
let you know the back of your head is
ridiculous but here's the worst part is
that she's trying to lure a guy in by
showing her breasts and I'm like what
kind of dude are you gonna attract that
he's gonna be like oh I want this girl
now now that I can see her titties and
how much they accentuate her I'm ready
to go and she's probably gonna be one of
them girls saying like oh you need to
stop objectifying women your shoes
I can't use your assets and yes to give
her lack of assets let's be clear
right she ain't had no titty game let's
not say she did no false ads still it
doesn't matter you shut up yeah she will
be completely I wish you would notice me
for me and all my qualities when you
lured him in with set
so cool look at me look at me you alone
now look at you what oh don't do it is
this video I felt Dumber right now it's
fast idiot oh and then she calls him an
idiot
that's one color like when girls
are CatDog you know when they get cat
call mmm
yo what's up baby you're good and the
girl doesn't respond oh yeah well it did
it are you that's what she
just did
right that's what the she just did
she's bitching and why guys don't get my
video on how we have guys listen first I
want to give you guys the best advice I
can give you don't ever take dating
advice regarding protein or how to get a
girl from a girl ever ever ever ever
ever ever they don't know what the
they're doing why because they don't
have to do it they don't have to engage
one man they got what we call
power
yes you know I mean I know it then you
know they go into a bar they can
literally just sit there like they can
be hooked on phonics half-retarded with
I hanging out and if she goes into the
barn asks enough dude one of those guys
can be like yeah you and let's go
and that's it it's a wrap women don't
have to do they can stand there and
just go point at people who like and
point at people like a Gollum
monster and some dudes gonna be like
yeah let's go girl
don't take advice from girls because
girls don't have skills to actually
approach and seduce women or or get
girls to want to be into you they don't
have that skill set you know what I'm
thinking right now what good laughing
cuz you know it's gonna be
all right all right he wants to get to
his own horn right mm-hmm go ahead
thought it with this members again
that's twice now yeah
toe toe sing it whoo imagine how
horrible it would be hmm
to go be dating a girl that's not being
shamed for which you she's just giving
me a passive-aggressive that's it
that's passive-aggressive right
here
do you really want to go out with that
hmm she makes a really good point
do you really want to go out with
someone who's manipulative like that
she's trying to manipulate him into
approaching her want to know why because
she's afraid to get her own ego
shattered and she doesn't want to deal
with that pressure so she's trying to
get a guy to do it for her that's all
for today's video does would you guys
think about this idea should women make
more of an effort to approach men should
men take advice from women from day we
wanna know what you think obviously you
know how we feel about it aspects shut
up Tina so you enjoyed that project
check us out on YouTube since that's
where we put everything we do we don't
try to put everything on Facebook
connect with us we'd like to talk to
everybody so yeah hmm